netflix ceo gives 3 million dollars to
beat
newsome recall not to beat newsome but
to beat
the recall there's a big difference
right so let's see why
netflix ceo is doing this so netflixio
gives three million dollars to beat the
news and
recall it's a political story uh he is
spending three million dollars to shield
governor newsom from a recall vote and
demonstration of the enormous um
some nuisance allies could marshal in
his defense according to a state filing
the massive outlay making hastings
by far the largest donor to the nuisance
recall campaign on the california rules
newsom can raise
unlimited sums to fend off a recall
effort that will likely land
before voters in the fall while other
gubern governor candidates are subject
to
campaign limits of thirty two thousand
four hundred dollars per election in
their direct accounts the hasting
contribution can punctuate
uh also punctuates a dramatic reversal
since newsom
ran for governor in 2018 hastings that
your port
seven million dollars into a charter
school driven political action committee
that supported nuisance democratic rival
former los angeles mayor
antonio villagrosa interesting so he
gave seven million dollars
to antonio tech leaders had
already signed on to a letter posing the
recall and pledging that their support
to
pledging their support for new thoughts
my thoughts are that he's probably
thinking that if there's a republican
governor in california it might be
somebody like desantis that
declares war on tech companies which
would directly affect him
so he's going to do everything he can to
prevent that you know i live there
there's no momentum for any candidate
whatsoever john cox is the former mayor
of sandy
san diego that's supposed to be one of
the big names throwing his hat in the
ring he just put seven million of his
own money into his own campaign you
don't see any ads
you don't hear anything there's no
there's no energy for anybody
unfortunately i think
you know newsome got very very lucky you
know uh california with all the tax
revenue
has helped him people are have short
memories you know they're thinking okay
it's better now it's opening up we'll
just go with what we have
now i read in the la times today that
there's a chance
because of the blackouts that could be
happening this summer i mean we're gonna
have a ton of fires again and then the
the
you know the grid in california has a
real hard time keeping up with the
electricity demands when the
when the weather goes up if there's a
lot of blackouts that could affect him
as well
but in order for newsome to lose there
has to be somebody that you want in
there and i just don't see
anybody having any momentum yet and by
the way he's not going to be the only
one you have unlimited
funds that you can use in a recall
election there's no limit on your war
chest
jj abrams has pledged money uh i saw the
ceo of
the 49ers you got the labor unions law
firms sending big bucks newsom's way
so i i but if you ask me about reid
hastings i think it has to do something
with protecting his business
yeah so you don't think our good friend
major williams that you're on the
podcast major
yeah you don't think he might have a
chance well 2022 i think he also
is thinking in the back of his mind
that's a good start right now well it's
just gonna be tough for anybody
and then you also got this guy meet
kevin who came out there and he was a
20-point plan he's talking about running
but basically i think ultimately what
you're saying is nobody has
the win behind them that has any chance
of beating
newsome especially when you have big
tech rallying behind him and he has
unlimited sums of money whereas i guess
other candidates
are subject to campaign limits of 32 000
per election
versus unlimited funds money talks baby
and it seems like newsome's got the
money i got a crazy quote i just
searched it right now i didn't know this
what do you think is the age to become a
governor president is what 35 30.
35 it's not it's not it varies by state
fyi okay most states
is 30. most the highest one matter of
fact nobody has it above 30 just so you
know every state is
highest 30. what do you think california
is 34
18. wow i'm telling you california ohio
i'm looking at it right now california
ohio
uh rhode island and washington and
wisconsin are the five states where to
be a governor is 18 years old which
means
do you think a guy like meet kevin he's
a hustler he's hungry he goes after it
he's not afraid
he's he's very good on camera great very
well spoken
understands money has strong opinions do
you think a guy like that could be a
governor in the state of
california a young guy like me kevin if
he's going against newsome zero chance
zero chance against news tell me why
well against newsom
tell me why tell me why tell me why
newsome clearly has big tech behind it
okay what else
okay so he called that instagram right
he's calling he sent me a message the
other day saying hey
you know i've been following your
content he's been following
valuetainment since a thousand
subscribers i said listen
i love your stuff as well you're killing
it so i follow him on instagram because
i like what he's doing
i would love to see a young cat like
that
come up out of nowhere and by the way
whether he wins or not
do you know how much energy it takes to
make a run for government like how much
energy all day every day i think
a young guy with a lot of energy by the
way my friend steve just sent me a text
message
right now okay and guess what the text
message is about
it's a text message he sent about meet
kevin
i got it at 10 19 which is 30 minutes
ago right meet kevin and he says i like
what he's talking about with newsome now
steve lives in california right
there are a lot of people that are
hoping somebody like him
comes up and makes a move and i think a
young guy with a lot of energy in a
state like california that's 18 years
old to run for governor and he's got a
few million subscribers
go at it so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye